Drives,
you know,
oh look,
Joe down the street just
became an internet millionaire.
What about us?
Well,
yeah.
What about you?
Maybe you could be an
internet millionaire too.
So lots of,
lots of great things
come out of crazy mania.
I mean,
lots of horrible things do too,
but there's always a price,
right?
The price of success is a lot of failure.
The price of success
is a lot of mediocrity.
So look at a university,
almost all the research that
started the university's wrong.
It's mediocre and wrong.
Some of it isn't.
Well,
you might say,
well,
we should increase the amount.
It's good.
It's like,
yeah,
no,
you probably,
you can probably,
what you can do is
increase the total amount.
So the total amount of good increases,
but I don't think you can do much about
the ratio because most things require a
lot of ways to move forward a lot.
So in a corporation,
like you know,
the corporate people are always saying,
well,
look at the university's ivory tower.
That's all rubbish.
Because in my experience,
people in universities are way less risk
averse than the chemical person in a
corporation.
Like a middle manager,
that's a shape.
Generally,
you know,
there's no risk in that guy at all.
He doesn't want to stand out at all.
He doesn't want to have a new idea who'd
be associated with what he wants to
hide,
where none of the predators can find it.
But even in a corporation,
say,
forget about all that,
97% of the corporation's activity
is just to keep itself going.
3% 4% 5% is profit.
So gigantic things to move forward,
to produce waste and uselessness all over.
And you're lucky if you get
some cream floating to the top,
so maybe you have to live with that.
That's,
that's how it is.